Katia devo assolutamente prenotare la
ceretta hai posto per il 23 Ma come sei
pieno Mi ma durante le feste tutte piene
siete è a Natale sei chiusa anche il 25
Vabbè ma Scusa annulla qualche tua
cliente capito nuova e lasci il posto a
me che sono tua cliente da una vita ah
non me ne frega niente Tu adesso mi
trovi posto perché sennò la volta buona
che vado a farmele fare da mia cugina e
stavolta non scherzo e quando riapri
Scusa il 9 gennaio e io come faccio Cioè
almeno per Capodanno Devo farmela la
ceretta totale Oh cioè io a capodanno la
voglio soffice come la neve liscia come
il mascarpone Mica mi vuoi far andare in
giro come uno Yeti Oh